[Música]
[Aplausos]
doce años tenía yo cuando le dije a mi
mamá que quería ir a unos juegos
olímpicos mientras todos mis amigos
estaban jugando yo me dediqué a entrenar
mientras todos mis amigos les decían a
sus mamás que querían ser bomberos o
querían ser policías igual que sus mamás
los tiraban a locos mi mamá también me
tiro a loca
yo no hice caso de eso yo tenía muy fijo
y muy claro lo que yo quería hacer yo
quería participar en unos juegos
olímpicos no tenía yo muy claro lo que
se necesitaba para llegar a eso
pero yo tenía muy claro que yo quería
ser participante de unos juegos
olímpicos y representar a méxico en unos
juegos olímpicos a los 13 años participé
en mis primeros juegos centroamericanos
a los 14 años participé en mis primeros
juegos panamericanos colocando me en
séptimo lugar en los 100 metros libres y
obteniendo medalla de bronce en ambos
relevos 4 por 100 metros combinado y 4%
relevo libre obtuvimos el único metal
que gméxico obtenido en juegos
panamericanos en natación
más adelante regreso y tenía que tomar
una decisión más drástica yo sabía que
quedándome en mexico no lo iba a lograr
yo le dije a mi mamá que me quería ir a
entrenar a eeuu
así que investigue y vi que el mejor
entrenador de eeuu era richard twiss
richard quick era el entrenador de la
selección olímpica femenil de eeuu en
ese momento así que le escribí y como
buena quinceañera me admitió y me dio
oportunidad de ir a austin a entrenar
hizo una excepción porque yo no quería
entrenar con los de categoría para eso
yo me hubiera quedado en méxico yo no
quería eso hizo una excepción y me dio
la oportunidad de entrenar con las
chicas de el equipo de las de la
universidad de austin así que un año
dejé la escuela sacrifiqué estar allá y
me dediqué a nadar regresé a méxico y
logré mi objetivo integrarme a la
selección mexicana de natación que fuera
representar a méxico en los ángeles 84
yo tenía 15 años ahora yo lo veo con mi
hija que tiene 16 y realmente es cuando
yo pongo en perspectiva lo que yo logré
a esa edad fue la primera mexicana en
bajar los 27 segundos en los 50 metros
libres
ese récord me lo acaban de romper hace
tres años ese récord duró 20 años
los récords son para romperse obviamente
no se siente padre que te rompan un
récord pero menos que dure 20 años yo
hubiera esperado que la anotación
mexicana avanzara mucho más rápido y que
el récord se pudiera romper más pronto
participó en los juegos olímpicos son la
segunda nadadora más chica participando
en los ángeles me colocó en lugar 17 un
gran orgullo para mí porque me quedé a
un lugar de participar en la semifinal
regreso a méxico y ya me tengo que
incorporar a mis actividades ya no mis
papas ya no me iban a dejar quedarme más
tiempo en eeuu sin estudiar así que yo
regreso a méxico y me incorporo a los
estudios pero lo fácil o lo difícil no
es llegar a la cumbre no es llegar al
campeonato lo difícil es mantenerse ahí
porque yo regreso y así como yo hay
muchas nadadoras queriendo quitarme el
liderazgo
yo me mantengo participó nuevamente en
los juegos centroamericanos otros juegos
panamericanos y vuelvo a participar en
unos juegos olímpicos mis segundos
juegos olímpicos a los 20 años me coloco
en lugar 23 mundial en los 100 metros
libres
eso me da la oportunidad de irme a
estados unidos con una beca y concluir
mis estudios allá a lo que voy en la
vida se nos presentan muchas
oportunidades muchas veces no nos damos
cuenta se nos presentan están en frente
de nosotros y no los aprovechamos
entonces estoy aquí para pedirles que
abran bien los ojos las oportunidades
están ahí si yo no hubiera tenido la
oportunidad esa inquietud de querer
participar en unos juegos olímpicos y yo
no hubiera tenido el apoyo de mis padres
no me hubiera sido posible ser una
nadadora exitosa y participar y hacer
historia porque hoy en día
orgullosamente digo soy olímpica
regreso a lo largo de la vida se me
presentan numerosas oportunidades
obviamente no todo corre padre y en mi
vida paso por un divorcio y eso me
regresa a la natación me invitan a
formar parte del primer relevo mexicano
que hace un cruce doble al canal de la
mancha el canal de la mancha es el canal
que se encuentra entre inglaterra y
francia es una distancia de 33
kilómetros nosotros lo hicimos y de
vuelta en un solo paso rompimos el
récord mundial obteniendo así la marca
que nadie nunca antes había logrado
formamos ese equipo seis mujeres seis
mujeres exitosas y ansiosas por obtener
el triunfo
además de eso me dedico a sigo siendo
nadadora sigo activa sigo participando
a mí en la vida la natación me ha dado
mucho me ha dado muchos viajes he podido
obtener muchos premios muchos
reconocimientos pero lo más importante
de todo esto es que he podido
representar a mi país he podido escuchar
el himno nacional y ver usar mi bandera
frente a mí entonces me despido de
ustedes diciéndoles que no tengan miedo
a ver esa oportunidad que está frente a
ustedes no tengan miedo a ser diferentes
y no tengan miedo a intentar algo que
nadie más lo ha hecho muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]